and minimalists hello simpletons don't
badger me you can't badger our audience
joke I just think I was gonna reclaim
the word well I guess you can't reclaim
it it's always been a pejorative
simpletons yeah but like Rihanna has the
Navy and Beyonce has the The Beehive I
figure we could have the simpletons
right anybody listen to this is a is a
simple it's a simpleton all right all
right we'll see if it sticks
I've heard you say that behind people's
boxes everybody I'm Joshua fields
Milverton and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists indeed
we are today we're gonna talk about
desire we're gonna talk about yearning
we're gonna talk about craving and
impulse and lust and longing and
aspiration with today's guests our
returning champion your Rollins is in
the building
thanks so much for being here mask we
have to be back I feel like we're all
dressed in black I feel like we're the
vampires not the minimalist but you got
the memo man very slimming yes why I did
yeah me too I don't I was explaining
this to my mother-in-law in Montana I
was just out there I was just telling it
I wear black because I don't know what
else to wear colors it's gonna go way
wrong so black and gray and then I'm
fine yeah we should add some gray in so
great now I just can't togas it's black
so Pete our last episode we did with you
episode 155 about love people absolutely
love them in that episode so today we're
going to talk about desire and since
you're the vice president of desire we
thought there's a president of desire
we've got some questions here today
before we dive into the questions the
reason I want to have you on to talk
about this is our mutual friend Rob Bell
you were talking about this concept of
object a on his podcast and as opposed
to rehashing that entire conversation I
was hoping maybe you could give us a a
quick synopsis because I've tried to
rehash it a few times on maximal
episodes of our podcast and I know
you'll do a much better job than me it's
a tough concept to get so we could spend
five
Podcast just talking about object day so
we were trying not to do that but by the
way this is almost a part to to love so
if anybody because love is all about
desire yeah so we when we talked about
love we're talking about desire so this
is kind of like a part two yeah so go
back listen to that one as well
object a okay how do we start we're
starting by talking about something that
doesn't exist right and that is already
a bit of a head spin our Heidi talk
about something that doesn't exist
because if something doesn't exist why
would you talk about it right so can we
talk about that for a second or two what
yeah what does it mean and by the way
that's what in philosophy that's what
the spiritual is in a way so right
people use the word spiritual in various
heebie-jeebie ways mm-hmm but but in
philosophy you could say that the
spiritual is the neom for something that
is non reducible to material reality
right so it's not so forget about kind
of like angels and fairies or anything
like that whether they exist or not the
spiritual is simply the name for what is
not Material mm-hmm people tend to go
one or two directions with that word
right they either try to get rid of it
entirely
crude materialism or they try to out
there professor Mia get into like a kind
of exactly right so those are two
extremes would each what do you do if
you try not to get into either of those
extremes so first of all what so here's
a here's an example of talking about
nothing zero zero like what is zero word
for a long time absolutely and you
Americans don't even have it in your
lifts right you go to Europe oh what's
the first floor zero zero because zero
is a number zero is one you can write I
can Guzzi there's one zero that's one
orgy which for the longest time I
thought meant garage I do even know in
America I will often press the wrong
floor because I'm black see in Europe
I'll press first floor because I've been
living here for so long and then I get
it-- up the wrong floor I'm not getting
out the ground floor so zero you guys
the Americans don't have a you start
with one and that makes sense you start
with one mmm
but no you start with zero because zero
is a number so as soon as as soon
we were able to to basically put a mark
around nothingness it was a real advance
within mathematics right so we're
talking about nothing in the same way
when we talk about they say the
unconscious we're not talking about
something we're talking about what this
stabilizes us we're not really talking
about something we're talking about this
this deadlock there's conflict within us
so object a what's that this is a
fictional object that we start to
fantasize a bite because we can't get up
right so I don't know if we talked about
this in the last episode but there's the
the pleasure principle is this idea that
I want stuff right when you're a kid you
want to climb all the trees you can
climb you want to eat all the chocolate
you can eat you want to win all the
games that you can play
that's the pleasure principle and then
reality principles what gets in the way
right you can't eat all the chocolate
you want cuz your parents will stop you
you can't climb all the trees you want
because your body won't let you you
can't win all the games that you want
because your friends want to win right
now that's reality and we start to we
start to fantasize about what we could
get if we could get rid of reality and
just have what we wanted and that
fantasy we start to imagine something
wonderful that if only we got it would
be wonderful
that's object a that's object a so it's
to change over time yeah and it can even
change throughout the hour right and
especially changes once we we get it yes
oh absolutely there's a beautiful
analogy that philosopher she's accusers
where he says so when Darwin was writing
supposedly he had this kind of young
earth creationist Christian friend he
was and that Darwin was like listen how
are you gonna reconcile my insights into
evolution with six-day creation ISM you
think the earth was created 6,000 years
ago and his friend said well God me at
the earthly cooled right so the fossils
are like just were put there right make
sense yeah exactly just like in a movie
you've got old cars they're not old cars
they're brand new cars right so fossils
are these
just things that God put there that
patina that God added yes use building
mirrors exactly exactly
and she's excess this is actually very
intelligent it's actually very clever
that's what object day is right every
time you get it all you've got is the
fossil but it's a fossil of something
that never existed hmm right so you
always feel like oh I got it and I
didn't quite get up and you're left with
the fossilized remains and you still
have the father say that that fossilized
remains kind of connects with something
what that might be in our culture right
now some of the the most manifest
examples of this or are you I want the
the the new house the new car the job
promotion the pay raise the new shirt or
pair of jeans what are some other things
that are sort of object day the the
thing that we yearn for and then of
course we get it and maybe it
temporarily seems to fill this void even
though it doesn't because we get a bit
of a dopamine rush yeah right gives us a
bit ahead yeah a little bit but then it
leaves us feeling empty the same way a
hit of a drug would do because you get
that same sort of dopamine rush from
that and then in a weird way you are
actually if you feel more empty than
ever because now you no longer have that
object a to pursue and then so what
happens you start to seek out whatever
the next object a is because all you're
left with is that fossil of this thing
that never really exists yeah you
explained this this concept of object a
to me probably like a year ago maybe and
we were having a drink and you explained
it to me and in my mind I'm like oh this
is the Tesla for me like for me I
because I live in LA and I'm like oh if
I get a Tesla I'm gonna enjoy LA more
and it's gonna make it so much more
enjoyable and I'm gonna like the car but
what I appreciate is that I understand
what my object a is yeah and I've
actually realized that the desire to
have the Tesla I enjoy more than if I
actually got the Tesla it's really weird
like I love the thought of getting it
but it's like I've had dreams about
getting a Tesla and it's such a letdown
I'm like oh
money on it even gives you dreams and
straight it gives you dreams and they're
wonderful it allows you to look online
and look at all of the stats and how
fast it can go and all of the tech you
can go into the the place and you can
test-drive it I mean let's be honest
that's where all the fun is and then of
course the day you get up it's fun but
it's not it isn't what it kind of
promises the promise is always a bit of
a lesson something is gonna replace it
so if I to give like the elevator pitch
for object day I would say object day is
that thing that we are constantly
looking at whether it's a relationship
or whether it's a physical item or
whether it's like a fantasy you know
status whatever it is there's something
that we're looking at in the distance
and we're like man if we could just
somehow get there we're gonna be
complete we're gonna be happy yes but
the whole concept behind an object day
is that once you get to that object it
just becomes a different object in your
life becomes something else and
something will get to you maybe not
right now but is that this isn't a bad
thing no it's it but it's just something
to start recognizing that this is a part
of hi we desire is actually what's even
worse is when you have a new object day
when when you have no desire doll I mean
depression in a sense is not you know
you know if you lose something that you
desire a person someone you breaks up
with you and you lose the person you
desire you don't just lose the person
you desire you lose what allows you to
desire anything at all so they're what's
called the object cause of desire so
your loved one is the object of your
desire and they're the object cause of
your desire so what that means is when
you lose the object of your desire you
lose the ability to desire anything so
you no longer care about your work you
no longer care like going out to
restaurants you no longer care about
Christmas you no longer you all the
things that you used to enjoy alongside
this person all suddenly disappear so in
one way depression is a high to get over
depression is high to get your desire
started again because your desire just
stops and you just don't even want to
get out of bed yeah it's very very very
difficult that's interesting this whole
object day thing is uh I think it's a
great lead in today's questionnaire
let's dive in Nate from Salt Lake City
has a question
hi my name's
I live in Salt Lake City Utah I want to
ask you what your advice is for making a
big life change making a big move my
girlfriend and I have been talking about
moving out of the state or we've lived
in Utah our entire lives we've talked
about moving out of the state and moving
somewhere else to start a new adventure
and try something different we love Utah
we want to try something different and
we've talked about it we've talked about
it and talked about it we've never done
anything about it I'm what tired of
talking about it and we want to do
something about it and I guess what
would be your advice to taking that
first step and actually making a big
move all right
so Pete it seems to me that well
previously Nate's object day was getting
a promotion at work and the Ryan and I
both worked in the corporate world we
both work for Telecom and that was an
object day for me it was one of my mini
object days I was I was juggling a lot
of empty fossils I feel like nate is so
much smarter than us because I could get
the promotion I'm like oh I haven't
climbed high enough right it was like
well now what's the next one right and
there's a weird part of me that feels
that maybe greatness requires misery to
some extent because III look at Michael
Jordan who's probably the greatest
basketball player of all time I would
argue against that but a lot of people
say that he is but he seemed utterly
miserable because he it almost required
that to a certain extent and now what I
would say about nate is he's gotten rid
of that object day for maybe a more
healthy object day he and his his wife
are looking to our girlfriend are
looking to move somewhere else and so
now it's a new destination new geography
is object day let's talk about where we
get the this concept of object day from
that's good yes let's talk about that
because I noticed something nyet said
just as the at the beginning he said
that his partner had given your
documentary to him shoot your
documentary to him and he really enjoyed
it this actually is a key to
understanding how where we get object a
from is the weird thing is we think our
desires are a room they're not they're
given to us by other people and this is
called mimetic desire there's a guy
called Rene Girard he really does
at work in this but that what happens is
when you're going out with somebody
because obviously your documentary is
terrible
and so nobody would actually like it
directly right I couldn't agree more yes
exactly but if someone else likes it and
I like them I start to like it because
they like it right this is mimetic
desire mimetic desire is this weird
thing where you start saying going out
with somebody and you start to like what
they like you start to find yourself
being in the French cinema and long
walks along the beach or whatever
they're in C and then weirdly you start
to think that they're your desires and
they they're into certain bonds and then
you start to be into those bonds and
then if you break up you start to fight
over humans the CDs I mean that's a
reverence die you lose your Spotify but
the interestingly what I desire is the
desire of ones I desire so that's the
most precious material in the world
right it's not Gould it's not health the
most precious material in the world is
the desire of the desire no the desire
of the people I desire yes I desire the
desire of those I desire I want thirds
are but also the second bits of that is
I desire what they desire because I if I
see that what they desire sometimes I
want to kind of take the place of that I
want I want the attention that they are
giving the other thing you imagine when
you're a kid and you see your parents
giving desire to something else and you
kind of want to kind of get that desire
so it's it's interesting it's important
to learn that because what Rennie Gerard
says he says the problem is this right
say right you're going right with
somebody just to use the example of
sexual desire and I think you're cool
which is a hard thing for your listeners
to imagine but I think you're crazy
my mom says the same thing yeah
but then here's the crazy thing right I
maybe start to desire who you desire you
say I really fancy this person and I'm
like oh and then I go like I really kind
of fancy them as well then what happens
is we get into conflict because alou
I've kind of taken the desire on because
of you I feel it's my own now we're in
conflict
with each other and it causes lots of
problems and and then we get into what's
called scapegoating and we have to blame
somebody else in order to kind of
reconcile so where does our desire come
from here's the funny thing is your
dessert you feel it's yours whatever you
desire but actually it might be the
desire of your mother your father your
siblings your friends your taking on all
of these other people's desires and
here's then even more complicated
sometimes you don't desire your desire
sometimes you end up in a job that you
kind of hit but you kind of choose and
so you obviously choose it freely
because that's what you wanted to do but
you also hear up and then you discover
that oh my goodness I'm fulfilling the
desire of my parents or I'm desire you
know this is the weird thing by being
human is we can not desire what we
desire I get a very complicated yeah our
book everything that remains the one of
the first lines on here is what if
everything you with everything you ever
wanted isn't actually what you want and
and I think that that that's what really
happened to me and Ryan like we grew up
really poor and he said well the key to
happiness obviously is for us to go out
get the corporate job work 80 hours a
week climb the corporate ladder make
really good money buy all the things we
have been deprived of the first 18 years
of our lives and we did that got
everything we ever wanted but of course
everything we ever wanted was an action
what we wanted there were mimetic
desires that they were there were the
the desires of a heavily mediated
culture that does a very good job of of
manufacturing desires through
advertisements and then sort of
propagating them through the the
proletariat and and so by age 30 Ryan
and I were sort of like scratching our
heads like hey what happened what and I
think Nate that's kind of where where he
is right now now he asks about moving
I'm not gonna go into a lot about that
right now because we did an entire
podcast episode called moving and really
about how to find the right place and
and how to test out a place for a short
period of time so we'll put a length of
that in the show notes if we can go back
to to that episode you can you can
listen to that Nate and I'd love to send
you a copy of our book
everything that remains it's really the
story of me and Ryan going from the
suit-and-tie corporate guys at the
wireless company at a telecommunications
company to becoming minimalists and not
getting rid of our desires but getting
more appropriate desires in a way kind
of owning your desire this the this this
is what Nietzsche talks about when he
says Umbria syou're Fiat what he kind of
means is it sounds strange at first but
when you come into the world you say as
it as an adolescent you start to
question you start to think you start to
kind of wonder what do I want in the
world you're already full of desires and
beliefs because from from years of being
brought up in a certain way and so it's
not that you start with an empty
shopping cart and you go into this
shopping mall of ideas and you take
stuff off the shelves and put it into
your shopping cart your mind right your
mind the shopping cart is already full
of stuff right and you have to pull
stuff out of it so sometimes the first
thing is to do is to go Heidi I kind of
Heidi I enjoy my enjoyment Heidi I
embrace my desire Heidi I make something
my own so it yes of course started
somewhere else it started because of in
various ways but Heidi I make my desire
my own and and not a not be tossed
around by like it like a ship without an
anchor yeah yeah all right we have
another question here from Chantelle and
Huntington Beach California hi guys I
got a text from my husband today that
said what moment from the last seven
days are you most likely to remember ten
years from now and I honestly could not
answer that question
and so I'm my question for you is what
would you suggest we do with our lives
to answer that question and say
something with conviction I work
full-time I go to school full-time my
husband works full-time commuting 90
minutes per day and I just feel like
we're in a rut right now where we don't
have a lot of
time for something that would let us
answer that question and feel good about
it yeah it's interesting man I think
there's like this Western idea that we
have to like constantly be living our
best life and we have to be asking these
deep questions like what are we doing in
the last seven days and it it makes us
feel like we have to have this like
grandiose action that we must take and
in in chantels case it's on a weekly
basis and I guess like what I want to
tell Chantel is like don't put so much
pressure on yourself
to do these grandiose things I mean it
could be something real simple that you
remember for the next ten years but I
think as soon as you put a number on it
like if she was to tell herself all
right I got to do something every seven
weeks so I'm gonna remember for the next
ten years I don't know if that's
possible you know what maybe rephrase
the question a little bit because I you
and I tend to disagree on the subject I
think it's because we use the wrong
words here I think you should be living
her best life well sure the best doesn't
mean perfect right like the best team in
the NBA does not have a perfect record
the best baseball player doesn't have a
perfect sort of hitting percentage they
just have the best and and so maybe if I
were to rephrase the question because I
do agree with you here Ryan that well
maybe we're confusing excitement for yes
for that's what I mean when I say best
okay I have to constantly be growing and
I have to constantly be excited right
and so maybe if I were to rephrase that
this and I'd really be interested to
hear what what Pete has to say about
this because he might not necessarily
agree instead of saying what moment from
the last seven days will you remember
ten years from now which is a powerful
question I don't think maybe it is what
I'm doing today or is what I'm doing
right now or is what I'm doing this week
will it matter a year from now and and
quite often I think we get so caught up
in these sort of ephemeral pacifiers the
the twitter arguments or whatever that
we if we step back we realize no this
isn't going to matter a year from now or
ten years from now it's not going to
matter two weeks from now right and so I
think Pete maybe what what Chantelle is
is talk
about here is is modifying her desires
to do something that matters yes yes yes
yes this is all very interesting - tale
by the way can I say that you know here
listen him how is it good
I I gotta say first of all you're
setting the bar very high because I
can't remember what I did ten minutes
ago so I like it but I thoughts just a
bad thing in my part I can't remember
anything here's an it I don't know if
this will go anywhere but I want to give
you an interesting saying by Cicero and
I'm not a stoic as such but sister was a
stoic and he said only only the wise are
rich right Alice it's an interesting
phrase because at first you go only the
wise are read so if you're loaded you're
wise that doesn't make sense right
there's lots of dumb people here know
that right yeah well it's very specific
it's not only the rich or wise it's only
the wiser rich exactly yes exactly
so already you can start to pick it
apart and one of the things he means is
if you're poor if you feel always that
you're lacking something that you need
to to get something in order to to feel
wealthy right so weirdly you could have
so much stuff you could have everything
but still feel you don't have enough so
you still feel poor whereas you could
you can't get to a place where as long
as your basic needs are met you don't
feel that you're you have to do
something in order for your life to be
rich and so he says only the wise rich
because he has a certain there's a
certain wisdom in umbria seeing the lack
and not not having to have something
that will fix it so you know it can't be
oppressive if you're looking for that
one thing that you'll remember for 10
years that can actually like you know
that that could create a lot of anxiety
to be honest I think a create a very
strong sense of lack and a real sense of
we have to do something that could can
lead to a sense of poverty so Heidi and
because here's the trick between the two
of you you're saying you sometimes
disagree and let's live your best life
and maybe you're like more of the get
rid of the idea of living your best life
yeah yeah and I you know
that could be a two sides of the same
coin that it really is yeah and you know
and we want to parse these things I know
that I you know there's real differences
but there's a certain sense in which
wanting to for example achieve things
have a life that is meaningful and yet
not a life in which you're always
pursuing something that just makes you
always feel like you haven't got there
right so how did Heidi do that I mean
I'm just asking questions here question
well yeah I thought alike two things
that I do in my life that I'm gonna
remember ten years from now one is one
is like a very specific example I went
snowboarding a week ago on January 11th
it was a year to the day and when it
broke my back in Montana and I have been
taking care of myself for like the last
year getting massages chiropractor you
know exercise diet and when I went to
face that mountain like there was like a
lot of anxiety but hey I was grateful
that like I had been taking care of
myself I was grateful that I had you
know got the care that I needed and then
be like I was grateful that I was able
to face that fear I went down the same
exact run this through the same exact
tree line
I like wave to the tree that broke my
back on the way down and if it felt so
good to go down there I was just
thinking about this is good cuz there's
a negative side to this because what is
it what are the things that we remember
for 10 years almost always pain yeah the
drama yeah and this is called repetition
compulsion so trauma is basically the
the idea that the past is never past
history isn't is always present so a
repetition compulsion is basically that
your past remains present always so you
keep repeating khipu and I have the same
type of person keep that so trauma is in
a sense what you never forget or you try
to forget but you remember it in your
body your body remembers and your
actions so so another angle on this that
you're taking that actually the trick is
how can we live a life where there's
nothing we remember 10 years from my
adoption my way the good life the good
life is
our friend Chris Chris Ryan who wrote
civilized to death one of my favorite
books and he he was talking about this
on his podcast recently he there was
apparently this awful serial rapist it
was a man who would hang out set of bars
and then lure other really really really
drunk men back to his house and then I
guess roofie them or it gives them some
sort of drug that made them pass out and
then he would rape them and videotape it
and eventually he got caught you know
long story short here and then they
found like all these hard drives the
equivalent of like 300 DVDs worth of his
footage of these scenes and I think it
was a hundred and ninety people that he
he did this to but almost none of them
knew that this happened to them and so
the police had a very fascinating sort
of moral dilemma because if you don't
know this happened to you and you know
as long as there were no consequences if
you didn't get some sort of fatal STD or
something like that and then do you tell
that person because were they
traumatized when the event occurred or
were they traumatized when the police
told them about it and I don't know the
answer to that I don't think any of us
actually know the answer to it part of
me is like yes of course I'd want you to
tell me that but then maybe even a more
rational part of me is like why would I
want that trauma thrust upon me yeah and
then the next level of this variant this
is a good philosophy question this kind
of thing you do in first-year philosophy
because then the next question is but
then if we knew that the police don't
tell us then we're going to be anxious
did that happen to me so then then you
get to the level of if the police don't
tell you do you have to have a society
where you do know that the police don't
tell you and then yeah so it's a really
very interesting circles yeah yeah yeah
no I just want to encourage chants out
like just you don't have to like go on a
trip every week you don't to like do
something grandiose like for me you know
getting back to the lake my back
I appreciate the little decisions I've
made on a weekly basis and like I look
back and I remember these decisions I've
made to keep good health and like to
take care of myself like that is
something
that you're gonna remember 10 years from
now it doesn't have to be this like oh
yeah memory what we climbed the top of
Mount Everest and we were living our
best life and we took that selfie we
posted it on Instagram and everyone was
like yeah Chantelle you're living your
best life every time I take a picture
and I do this when I take pictures and
whatever I'm trying to capture a moment
to remember it but sometimes not always
but often a healthy life is a life in
which we're able to enjoy what's going
on but not try to capture so because
here's a trick in psychoanalysis one of
the main reasons why people come to the
analysis is because they live in the
eternal right that time is stopped
nighttime hasn't stopped physically
they're still getting old but something
has happened in their life that doesn't
get old just let you know if I say two
plus two equals four it doesn't get old
even if I get old two plus two equals
four just remains as young as ever right
um in the same way somebody might break
up with a person and the PM ten years
later it's just it's just as young and
it's busy so they're caught in the
eternal they're caught in that's that's
kind of the repetition thing they're
caught in time is stopped in some
dimension in their being time is stopped
and the task is to get time moving again
and sometimes the ability to just kind
of like enjoy the ride and not try to
capture a moment no matter how amusing
it is you climb my dare first fantastic
but tomorrow you're gonna make a really
good sandwich and you know I'm kind of
like you're that same joy that's a - as
much as you into it every the moment
actually ruins the moment yeah yeah
eternal eternity is not always good and
I say whenever someone has a trauma
where they knew that because a trauma is
something that steps out of time when
you have a trauma it weirdly jumps out
of temporality and it just stays as
young and nasty as ever
so eternity is not always good yeah I
mean yeah anytime Chantelle can
experience a little growth in her life
like that's that's what she's gonna
remember ten years from now yeah whether
it's health-wise whether it's overcoming
of fear because that's what I'm gonna
remember the most ten years from now
it's not the back pain it's gonna be
facing that anxiety and the fear like
that it felt really good like I heard
your story I was thinking like what and
in a way the Troma was there but when
you conquered up time started again and
you know that's what that's when time
stuff absolutely I can't even tell you
how nervous I was like when I first like
booted up yeah it was like it was I've
never been that anxious putting on a
snowboard yeah and it was and it was
just muscle memory yeah from the Troma
was crazy Chantelle I'm gonna send you a
couple tickets to our less coast tour
we're going on tour again we've got
eight cities along the west coast of the
United States and Canada we're gonna be
going to some other cities as well so if
you're interested just head on over to
the minimalists comm slash tour you can
find the city that is closest to you or
sign up for our email list we'll let you
know when we're coming to your city
we're gonna give a talk and do a live
version of the minimalist podcast in
those cities all right Ryan what time is
it it is time for our lightning round
where we answer questions from people's
text messages I've really been enjoying
this community thing man it's been been
fun connecting with people on a on a
personal basis I mean Josh sends a lot
of dick pics but other than that I'm
really enjoying it right peep so what
we've been doing is Ryan and I we have
this phone number by the way if you're
listening to this at home nine three
seven two oh two four six five four
people can text us directly and write to
both of our phones right now as to your
food yeah I'm gonna test it and see if
it's not true I'm gonna tweet it bye
okay wait do let me tell you I so I went
over to Peter's house like I don't know
a couple months ago was right after we
did the apartment tour AHA and he was
like dude I gotta give you I gotta give
you a little [ __ ] after your apartment
or he was like what he was like I've
been to your apartment man he's like you
own way more than what you had showed on
that video I'm like picture I saw this
pic yeah Adi was sitting in his
meditation watching video did you he was
like no I didn't because he instantly
was like aha Ryan's totally like full
and all his eye
very fun exciting all I saw was the
picture I was like I'm gonna give him
she's just my way of saying he will call
us out you can check out Ryan's Home
Tour we'll put a link to that in the
show us as well
you can text us your questions we don't
respond to everyone's we I've responded
to over a thousand text messages now oh
my goodness and I've had a lot of fun
I've learned that people ask some
questions via text they wouldn't usually
ask via social media but you can follow
us on social media too like it's at the
minimalist wherever you you work well
whatever social media platforms you're
on but and you're at Peter Rollins on
Twitter yeah but we got some questions
here Ryan let's dive into those ooh all
right April wrote in can you talk about
lust and yearning for others when in a
marriage
interesting so here we're trying to do
Pete we try to do we try to answer these
questions with short shareable less than
140 character good luck responses we
call the minimal Maxim's we people can
copy and share share them from our show
notes share them on social media if
you'd like and you can find all of our
minimal Maxim's in one place minimal max
you just ramble on and podcast Shawn
we'll make it nice and pretty on post
yeah here's my pithy answer and then we
can we can unpack it a little bit
getting everything you want metastasizes
into not having what you need mmm I
think sometimes we we get everything
that we want or that we think we want I
do it with cake all the time but but
when we do that yes a cake is a really
good example we get these sort of empty
calories of consumerism or whatever and
we end up forsaking what we actually
need the the nutrition so to speak right
you can live off of cake for a while
because it has all the macronutrients
you need it does not have the
micronutrients oh so what's the saying
man cannot live on cake alone so what do
you think the the can you talk about
lust and yearning for others when in a
marriage that's that's object day again
in 140 cars so that's here it is one's
lust is not the problem is the solution
to your problem Wow damn I'm not even
gonna read my answer
now you know what uh here's my pithy
answer it's just it's real simple honest
communication creates lasting
relationships and what I mean by that is
you know what if you want to talk about
lust and you want to talk about other
people that you are attracted to talk
about them with your partner yeah that
means niala often like we'll check out
people together I love it dude Mariah
and I like I mean we're very open with
it I mean I'm a little bit more open
than she is but but you know what that
creates it creates a lot more trust
between us and a lot stronger bond where
she can be like we just looking at that
girl's button I'm like yeah I got eyes I
use them then it's it makes it a nice
little moment for us like it's not it's
not anything that that we can't handle
as a mature couple because the
alternative is what repression yeah it
becomes very secretive then it becomes
even more desirous and then and here's
the funny thing about this about lust as
a desire is that on we don't see this we
don't feel it but I think we kind of
know what's true is the more like you
yeah I'm a romantic right a romantic as
someone he'll kill it kid just to have
sex with a person right so I am a
hopeless romantic right and you know
they will kill an orphanage full of kids
just to have a woman night with the
person killed
killing the kids to have sex with an
adult in your head except my morals
they're like he's killing a lot of kids
but it isn't not all these obviously
right so but that is the kind of the
hopeless romantic in a very negative
sense is you'll to be anything you'll
cut off your arm to be with the person
but the idea being that then when you're
with them they the left on is huge right
that the more that you have to do the
more the obstacle the the more the
desire and then the more the latter and
so lust functions in a very difficult
way that so for example somebody's like
I just will I'll leave my wife and my
kids and I'll leave everything my job
I'll give up all my money I'll give up
everything to be with you and then the
person says yes
and then three months later yeah yeah
yeah that's the problem that's the
service they killed all those kids yeah
that was a bit of a disaster and I check
that back you know Dada is deaf the
ultimate laugh time so when you're
almost to bite your desires with another
person and you can at least take the
edge off the the the lost you know so
it's a yeah I think the thing there is
will wrap up the segment on on this but
with the when you said the lust isn't
the problem when you get the the other
person or whatever you end up being the
problem not you're not the the thing
that you got because you had a different
sort of expectation you an expectation
in your mind that once I get this thing
I will be complete or I'll be better or
I'll have what I want or my all of my
desires will be met and what a poor
expectation that is because here's a
trick I'm sorry I know it has to be
quick you listen all very like lightning
Rhine but the the problem with romantic
relationships for most of us is problems
of desire like whenever people lust
after somebody else and it's always how
do we manage how do we keep our desire
alive how do we manage our desire how do
we make it productive so whenever
someone wants to have an affair has an
affair when there's loss usually when I
say it's a solution to your problem is
the problem of desire there's a there's
a deadlock and desire in the
relationship this is a frantic attempt
to fix that but it's a bad attempt like
it doesn't work it causes peein so
always when I see things like like
affairs and lust I'm asking what is that
trying to solve words the deadlock of
desire in the relationship and you have
to solve out yeah yeah all right before
we dive into our added value segment and
our listener tips today it looks like we
got a bunch more surprise questions this
week can a person's desires ever be
truly satisfied or are we cursed to
perpetually feed them is there a
difference between mimetic desire and
personal desire we'll talk about the
difference between the two there how do
you reconcile personal desire with guilt
and beliefs the desire to not be
attached to desires as this
in itself No detach from the desire did
not hold on to any desire man actually
it's a fairly deep philosophical
question and we'll dive into that with
Pete also is there a difference between
being impulsive and being spontaneous
and our our desires tied to our fears
and vice-versa also five insane ideas
about sex from ancient philosophers and
a bunch more questions for our friend
Peter Rollins and if you want to hear
all that I feel like that question needs
to be like a hit hits blunt meme what if
your is in the hits blunt mean I'm sorry
this week's maximal episode that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different much longer
a much more personal maximal episode on
the minimalist private podcast which is
the best way for us to fund this podcast
and keep it a hundred percent
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll also receive a personal
link so that our maximal episodes play
in your favorite podcast app find all
the details over at the minimalists com
slash support Ryan what else you got for
us this week it's time it's time to
listen to our listener comments and tips
and voicemails check them out hello this
is Bryce from Delray Beach Florida I
wanted to share a tip that I came up
with to live a more balanced and
intentional life what I did was I have a
planner that instead of going by the
hour it goes by the different realms of
health and it made this really cool
acronym that's easy to remember and easy
to apply and that's special every day is
special and every day is an opportunity
to grow spiritually physically
emotionally communally intellectually
adaptively and lucrative lee hey guys
this is tracy from Denver Colorado I'm
calling to say thank you because in
early 2017 I listen to your podcast the
finances and budgeting and you kept
talking about Dave Ramsey and I I
started going into that rabbit hole
listening to his
Cass and because of that and the
knowledge that you guys share I'm
sitting here tonight with this being the
last night I ever have debt and if my
final payment tomorrow and it'll be
debt-free for the first time in 23 years
I've been busting my butt at this for
one year and 363 days so I am extremely
excited to celebrate this milestone
tomorrow and I thank you guys because
prior to listening to those podcasts I
was just looking for a way to figure out
how to manage my finances better and it
felt so difficult and complicated and
you guys made it so easy and shared
information and it has changed my life
alright y'all thanks again to Peter
Rollins for joining us today you can
check out his website actually follow
him on patreon if you get an opportunity
he does some amazing lectures and he
dives deep on philosophy but in a way
that is actually interesting and not
it's not gonna put you in a coma he is
he's so introspective but he's also I
don't know as you've seen throughout
this episode here he has a way of
tackling questions and diving deeper in
a way that keeps you interested yeah
it's like the philosophy behind the
philosophy yeah it's really good so
patreon.com slash Peter Rollins you can
also follow him on Twitter he's at Peter
Rollins on Twitter and Instagram follow
him over there we'll put a link to his
website in the show notes as well and
real quick four right here right now oh
and by the way check out his podcast the
fundamentalists is the name of his
podcast I really enjoy him in his
roommate his roommate is a comedian he's
a philosopher and they wax philosophical
but in a very funny way each week over
on the fundamentalists podcast and real
quick four right here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalists we want to encourage you
to get clear on your values it is a new
year and you'll hear Ryan and I talking
about aligning your short-term actions
with your long-term values well you can
only do that if you know what your
values are otherwise your values are
going to be thrust upon you by the
society writ large and that is a recipe
for discontent so get clear on what your
value
so Ryan and I believe there are four
different types of values and we put
together this free values worksheet and
I also wrote an essay to go along with
it called how to understand your values
you can find that over at the
minimalists comm /v as in values and you
can download the free worksheet over
there as well you can follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalists and if you
have a question comment or minimalism
tip for our podcast email a voice memo
to podcast at the minimalists comm you
can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists and if
you want our show notes in your email
inbox each week then sign up for our
email list over at the minimalists comm
you'll also receive our simple Sunday
emails each week for our added value
this week I thought this was the perfect
song since we're talking about desire
Noah Gunderson he's one of my favorite
songs of his is a song called bad desire
from his album white noise so proud to
value this week let's listen to bad
desire from Noah Gunderson and if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time and minimus
[Laughter]